le projet passionnant puisqu'il s'agit
d'immerger les français dans
l'informatique il est ambitieux il est
aussi bien difficile à mettre en
pratique
jean-jacques servan-schreiber président
du centre mondial informatique annoncé
un plan interministériel de 5 milliards
de francs qui vise à équiper de
micro-ordinateurs la plupart des villes
françaises pour que leurs habitants
puissent se familiariser avec ces
technologies
outre le coup le projet se heurtent à
d'autres difficultés celles de la
concurrence entre des fabricants
américains plus compétitif et des
fabricants français qui veulent
conserver le marché dit schwarz des
adultes qui retournent à l'école pour
s'initier à l'informatique c'est encore
aujourd'hui un phénomène rare pourtant
dans un an ce doit être un acte tout à
fait banal pour cela il suffirait que le
projet de jean-jacques servan-schreiber
président du centre mondial informatique
soit approuvé par le gouvernement
il s'agirait d'installer d'ici à la fin
de l'année prochaine deux cent cinquante
mille micro ordinateurs dans les
établissements scolaires de tous les
villages et villes de france ces
ordinateurs seraient mis gratuitement à
la disposition de tous ceux qui
voudraient se familiariser à
l'informatique pour l'utiliser dans leur
vie professionnelle
si l'idée est louable elle pose
plusieurs problèmes un problème
financier d'abord parce qu'il faudrait
dégager sur le budget là quelques 5
milliards de francs
mais surtout elle pose un problème
politique le micro ordinateur utilisé
serait en effet une machine américaine
le macintosh fabriqué par apple le
numéro un mondial de la micro
informatique
de quoi provoquer une irritation de bull
le champion français des ordinateurs je
crois qu'un tel projet pose de très très
nombreux problèmes qui concernent
notamment l'environnement la logistique
l'accueil de ces micro ordinateurs la
formation des gens chargeaient les faire
fonctionner les progiciels qui
tournerait sur ces micro ordinateurs
pour notre part en tant qu'industriel
et avec notre partenaire thompson nous
sommes prêts à examiner tout projet et à
faire tout ce qu'il faudra pour dès lors
qu'il s'agirait d'un grandes ambitions
nationales pour la faire réussir
apple est un excellent concurrents nous
admirons beaucoup ses produits et son
dynamisme mais nous mêmes nous sommes en
train de lancer un produit que vous
voyez là qui est à nos yeux tout à fait
excellent qui a bien et mérite et nous
entendons le faire réussir sur le marché
français apple de son côté reconnaît que
la bénédiction des pouvoirs publics
ressemblerait à l'introduction d'un loup
américains dans la bergerie française de
l'informatique est un loup beaucoup plus
gros que nous 40 fois plus gros que nous
qui s'appelle ali ben qui est à la fois
dans le domaine de l'informatique et les
télécommunications
je crois que apple représente peut-être
pour l'industrie française un
contrepoids utile à vrai dire apple ne
manque pas d'arguments pour séduire le
gouvernement et les futurs utilisateurs
d'ordinateurs il propose en effet de
s'associer avec la compagnie générale
d'électricité à l'échelle mondiale mais
aussi de construire une usine dans
l'hexagone